hi everybody bill manning here from
northwest local land services
just thought we'd remind everybody of a
few summer cropping issues we've had
some great rain around the northwest and
prospects for summer crops are looking
quite good at this stage
but we have had many issues where
paddocks have been flooded and inundated
with moisture and that can create a few
issues for cropping
one of those is that flooded paddocks
can seal at the surface our high clay
soils can seal off somewhat like a dam
and this can reduce moisture
infiltration into the soil profile
so if you have had a flooded paddock and
you're thinking that it's full of
moisture
best to go around with a soil corer or a
probe and just check those moisture
levels before you make a decision about
summer cropping
the other issue that can occur with
very wet verticals is denitrification
the soil microbes that live in the soil
and feed off organic matter
like you and i require oxygen to carry
out those processes usually they obtain
that from the air like we do
but
under conditions of water logging they
can get their oxygen from nitrate
molecules in the soil
nitrate is the main
form in which soil nitrogen is stored
after they extract that oxygen the
nitrate component of the molecule can
then be lost to the atmosphere as gas
and this represents uh a loss from our
cropping system
and so once again
if you have had soils that have been
flooded or
inundated
think about doing some soil nitrate
tests before you make nitrogen
application decisions in the summer
remember that the nitrate may not have
been lost it may have just been pushed
further down the profile
in which case it will not become
available until later in the crops
growth cycle
a few people are already talking about
double cropping this year maybe putting
some mung beans into this cereal stubble
i would urge caution in that we still
have a few months of
crop growth to go and our winter cereal
crops still have plenty of time to draw
down that soil moisture
before maturity
and if we get a drier spring early
summer
our soil moisture levels could be
depleted under our cropping country so
once again
this is an opportunity for you to inform
yourself about paddock conditions before
you make a decision
okay then thanks very much
you